Okay, welcome everybody to another Zoom call.
There are some new people here.
You come in to the Zoom call automatically muted.
Most people will chat in their question
if they have a question, but I will not answer those.
I won't get those until I get through all the questions
that were submitted.
So if you think of a question,
during the Zoom call, feel free to chat
in the chat part of the Zoom app there.
Or if you do want to speak it in for any reason,
then you'll have to unmute yourself.
But if that's the case, please wait until after
we get through these questions.
Remember the member site is the key place
where you find all information, all announcements, et cetera.
So make sure you use the member site.
Okay, first question, is a ketogenic diet appropriate
for every cancer patient?
So if you've been with me long enough,
you know the answer to that is no.
So in general, though, doing a keto-like type diet
would be, I guess, appropriate for every person, period,
not even cancer.
You don't want to be eating a lot of sugar.
So when you're eating a ton of carbs,
I know there are carbohydrates,
the halux, carbohydrates, you know,
root deterians, all this kind of stuff out there
in the world and you could find some YouTube videos
on people that only eat grains or I don't know.
I just don't know that that's how we were mentally
and certainly people that are vegetarians
are certainly eating a lot more carbohydrates in general too.
So but I would suggest that it would probably be
in the best interest of most people of the planet
to be eating less carbohydrates.
Certainly most people in the United States
since we have been a pharmacolic nation for a long time.
So eating the more of a keto-like diet,
to think that keto diet is technically getting in ketosis,
to think that we all need to be in ketosis
is I think very incorrect.
Our cells are made to feed off of glucose
and that's how we produce energy.
But for a cancer patient,
to never cancer patient be on a ketogenic diet.
No, I don't think so either,
but again, eating more keto-like would be more appropriate.
Next question, we have another keto question.
I'm doing keto.
It's tempting to buy plant-based dairy products
to take the place of real dairy,
such as cream cheese, cheese, yogurt, et cetera.
But looking at these ingredients in these plant-based substitutes,
they look a little bit like fracon foods, isolates, gums, et cetera.
Is it better to void these altogether
or are all these additives relatively harmless?
Well, I would say some are relatively harmless,
some of the gums and some of the other different substitutes
that they use.
You can develop antibodies against it
so that you could have sensitivities to it.
But some of the fibers and stuff that they use
are relatively harmless.
You'd have to look up each ingredient.
Obviously, it's much better to eat real dairy,
but we're trying to stay up here on a dairy-free diet.
You can't do that.
So just stay away from some of those things
are probably the best.
As far as yogurt, like there's coconut milk,
yogurt's out there that I think are just fine.
Most of the dairy yogurt that you find out there
unless you're getting it organic
has got a bunch of additives and garbage.
Most of the dairy products,
unless you're getting it clean, dairy, clean, organic
or from the farm or something like that,
it's gonna have a bunch of garbage in it as well.
So just because it's dairy doesn't mean that
it's necessarily going to be good for us either.
So there's a lot of nasty stuff even in
what we would term as real food as well.
So next question.
Don't tumors continuously shed cancer cells?
I think they're talking about tumor cells.
They're shedding circulated tumor cells.
It's hard to imagine that they do that and fits and spurs,
but maybe they do.
I think it's hard to imagine that tumors
will release circulated tumor cells in pulses or spurs,
but maybe they do.
But if they shed continuously,
then why would anyone ever have zero circulated tumor cells
if they do have a tumor?
Even if some have moved on to tissue or to the liver
there shouldn't still be some in the blood
if there be a continuously shed, no?
Well, there's no data that tells us how
and when growing tumors will most likely
be releasing circulated tumor cells.
I have said over the years that I don't put a lot of faith
in the circulated tumor cell test
because I have just seen through my patient based,
patients that have done the circulated tumor cell test
have come back with elevated circulated tumor cells
but no other evidence of cancer growth
or the opposite, they've come back with no circulated
tumor cell evidence in the test
and yet have all sorts of other evidence of tumor growth.
So given that data,
then I would say that for someone
to have zero circulated tumor cells in the blood
is not a typically valid test to say
that the person doesn't have any cancer growth
or the cancer is dead or the cancer is walled off.
Again, like any lab that you do,
any lab has variables and any lab is there to give you clues.
It gives you ideas, nothing's gonna be perfect.
I'm gonna do this test and this is gonna tell me
if I'm cancer-free or this is gonna tell me
if my cancer is growing like crazy.
None of that one test is gonna be perfect in that scenario.
Even your gold standard PET scan,
you could have a very rapidly growing new tumor
that is metastasized in your liver, let's say,
but it's still only two million cells large
and it's not picked up by the PET scan
so you could be given a no evidence of disease
from your oncologist and yet you have a lot of evidence
of disease, you have a lot of disease,
they just haven't found the evidence yet.
So that's why they term it that way.
The test doesn't show that there's cancer,
it doesn't mean that there's not cancer.
And likewise, you could have something light up on a PET scan
and yet it was just metabolically active
at that time of the PET scan.
It's not really actively growing.
That's why you wanna compare with other previous test.
If you have a previous PET scan to see,
okay, let's look at the size.
Well, it is metabolically active in the lung here,
but it's actually smaller than it was before
or it's much larger than it was before.
So you're getting these clues from these tests
and you look at other labs.
Well, has this, as the alkaline phosphatase going up,
has the calcium levels going up, is it?
So no test, I know we all want.
I just want to run this test and know exactly where I'm at.
Well, I could lie to you.
I mean, oncologists tend to do that a lot.
They just tell you what you want to hear,
but that's not true.
So I just want to be giving you real data
that is not as possible.
None of these tests are gonna be perfect.
None of these tests can just call my heart
that we're all okay.
There are none of these tests should cause us to freak out
because we just don't know the full story.
And we're not at that place in modern medicine
yet that is gonna give us that full data yet.
So you have to use differential diagnosis
and use as much data as you possibly can
to come to the best conclusion,
to make a decision whether you should change treatment.
And to what degree you should change the treatment
that you're already doing.
So sometimes I think that, you know,
I know as humans we want to know
that everything is black and white
is my tumor turned on, there's a turned off.
I just need to know and we need to know this data.
And I know that some of us are more analytical
and more linear than others than we want
to have this information
because it really helps us in our decision-making process.
And I'm like that, that's me.
And the more you learn, the more you learn
that that's just not what life is like.
And I think that sometimes God doesn't allow it
to be like that because it forces us
to do either dependent upon who we're gonna put,
who are we gonna put our faith in?
You know where we're gonna put our faith in the tester?
We're gonna put our faith in the treatment
or we're gonna put our faith in the Lord Jesus
and our Heavenly Father that He's gonna guide us.
So during difficult times of our life,
whether it's cancer or it's financial issues
or it's a death of the family, it has to,
we have to let those things drive us
to a deeper relationship with Him
so that we can have that intimacy with our Heavenly Father
and that dependence upon that relationship.
So we can have peace in whatever decision that we're making.
And I know, oh, that's two of two.
So I just don't want that.
I want to get the science.
I want the data.
Well, that's just not what life is about.
So there's nothing wrong with seeking information.
There's nothing wrong with learning as much as you possibly can
but it all ends up bouncing back to,
we have to depend on the Lord.
I'm gonna get as much data as I possibly can.
Knowing that science is imperfect
and it's changing on a daily basis.
And then I have to ultimately fall back
on my relationship with Him
and depend on Him for my answers.
Okay, next question.
Researching the curcumin in raw tumeric,
it turns out that there's only between three
and 10% of curcumin in raw tumeric root.
So I understand curcumin is considered to be the active form
of the tumeric.
In tumeric, so tumeric is the root.
Curcumin is a curcuminoid that's in the,
in the plant, in the plant.
And that's the thing that studied
is the separated curcuminoids
in a lot of the studies that are out there.
So when you see curcumin helps kill cancer
or curcumin helps decrease inflammation,
most of the studies are done with the curcumin.
They're the most cure form of curcumin,
typically the 95% curcuminoids products that are out there.
So next part of this question.
In looking at supplements,
some of them say standardized to 95% curcuminoids.
So with this mean that if the supplement contains
let's say a thousand milligrams of tumeric
that somehow they've concentrated the curcumin
in the product that there's probably 950 milligrams
of curcumin, I believe that's what it means.
But here's the caveat on that.
So most of the studies that are done on supplements,
like I said with curcumin are,
is the separated curcumin.
But there's more, more data out there
that isn't basically included in studies
that the whole food of the product
may actually have more value
than the curcuminoid portion.
So you can't argue with, okay,
X amount of grams of curcuminoids
have decreased tumer growth, et cetera.
But does that mean that you shouldn't use
the whole form of tumeric?
So I am a fan of whole food
philosophy,
meaning that the way God created tumeric
with all the other curcuminoids that are in it
and all the other cofactors and phenols
and alkaloids that are in the tumeric
can actually have a synergistic relationship
and actually help the curcumin that is in it
actually function better.
So I know when this person wrote this question
because we had spoken the other day
and we talked about, she uses raw tumeric root,
grown up and basically she doesn't juice it
but she's blending it into a smoothie
and I told her I thought that was a better idea
but you could search for how many grams of curcumin
are in the tumeric root and she did so
and she saw that only about 10% of curcumin,
there's only about 10% of curcumin in a raw tumeric.
So if you have 10 grams of raw tumeric
you're only gonna get about one gram of curcumin.
Now that is probably true, I'm not doubting that
but we can't forget that there's synergistic benefits
of the whole food.
So I would recommend that you continue your practice
of using turmeric and I would bet
if you had a kitchen scale and you weighed your raw tumeric root
that you could get, I don't know how many grams
you could get in your serving that you're blending
in your drink but if you got 10 grams
in your drink you may only be getting one gram
of pure curcumin but it's a synergistic effects of that
that it actually may function as six or seven grams
of curcumin in your body.
So there's huge benefits to whole food nutrition.
There's so many of the studies of nutrition
are from synthesized supplements, separated supplements
if you wanna read more about it
then you could read into Western prices work.
I'm very much a fan of that philosophy
of the way God created it.
This is the way we're supposed to eat it.
And sometimes in the nutritional realms
things have been separated out and synthesized
and though it can be studied
you need much higher doses to get the same effects
as if you would have just eaten the whole raw food.
So long answer to, I think you should stick
to staying with the raw tumeric root.
Next question, I just read that we only absorb
about 15% of ashwagandha that take it in powder form
is this true.
So that could very well be true.
Ashwagandha is almost always gonna be in powder form
except I think silver now has a liposomal ashwagandha.
Maybe a couple companies have a liposomal ashwagandha
anything that you put in a liposomal form
is gonna be much better absorbed.
But all other ashwagandha is gonna be in a powdered form.
Your absorption rates of any of your nutritional supplements
is not gonna be like super.
So it's, you're only gonna absorb so much
that's why in a liposomal form
you're gonna be able to absorb any nutrition much better.
The negatives about, well why don't I just buy everything
in a liposomal form is because the number one
there's not very many supplements
that are available in a liposomal form
and number two, they're much more expensive.
So that's why typically they're not used.
There's some supplements that are just so poorly absorbed
that taking a liposomal form is so much better.
It's like when glutathione came out
and I don't know if it's on glutathione here,
but when glutathione came out of the form
that it was in that just was so poorly absorbed
then they came out with the esacetal glutathione
that was much better absorbed
and then the liposomal glutathione is even
farly much better absorbed.
So next question, when deciding blood water
what should I choose?
Hold on one second here, hold on one second,
we're just gonna pause this one second.
When deciding on regular blood work,
what should I choose?
So typically it depends on your case.
So everybody's gonna be different as far as what I would
recommend for blood work, but in general,
everybody should be getting a CBC with differential
that's a complete blood count with differential
and a comprehensive metabolic profile.
Not a standard metabolic profile,
lots of times if you go to your doctor
let's say you have Medicare,
they're gonna run the cheapest blood work as possible
as for a comprehensive metabolic profile.
If I haven't done record,
if I haven't ordered blood work on somebody before,
looked at their thyroid,
typically when I order the blood work
or also order a complete thyroid panel
because we wanna differentiate between somebody
who has either a very hypo thyroid condition
that has never been diagnosed and or a Hashimoto's
that has never been diagnosed
versus somebody that's having a lot of fatigue
from an anemia.
So anemia obviously is very common with cancer,
but many cancer patients, the diagnosis cancer
have never actually had complete blood work
to even diagnose whether they had a comorbidity
of low thyroid issue.
So I always like to screen for that and rule that out.
Once we see that that is within normal range
than typically the second blood work that I'll order
for a person that I would omit that.
And I might run some other tests.
Also if you have cancer and you haven't had tuber markers
done, then running a tuber marker panel can be valuable
if your female, obviously the female
or the male tuber marker panel added to that as well.
That would be just general blood work that we would look at
that would give us clues and I have made a lot of videos
and blog posts about a lot of those markers
that you'd find in that panel, in those panels
that I just discussed and what they would mean.
If you want more information on tuber markers
then you can look up the blog post on tuber markers
and there's an exhaustive information on that
and videos on that as well.
But obviously there's a lot of other blood work
that could be run to help diagnose a different conditioner
to help figure out something else that's going on as well.
I've been reading a lot of information about di-methyl sulfoxide,
DMSO and the healing properties for both external
and internal use.
What are your thoughts on DMSO?
Well, DMSO came out back in the 70s.
It was really popular as an anti-inflammatory topical.
It's literally like water.
It's viscosity and it's easy and cheap to buy on Amazon
and anybody can get it.
It could be as strong anti-inflammatory
but it can be a methyl donor
and it's definitely a sulfur donor.
So people used to like lather up their knee
when they hurt their knee or they hurt their wrist
and they're going to splatter it all over their wrist
and understand it literally is like water.
So if you open up the bottle and it literally pours like water
and you could dump it all over your body.
The negative is that it's a methyl donor.
It is an anti-inflammatory
but it is a sulfur donor as well
which can have negative effects depending
on if you have a lot of CBS gene defects.
You could push that pathway hard
and you could end up with issues
and I have multiple videos on that
if you have a CBS over production or under production
and that could be an issue with people.
But using it typically or even orally
for a very short period of time,
typically that's not going to be an issue.
Because it's a sulfur donor,
you also will get the taste of garlic
and your mouth very strongly and like immediately following.
DMSO also absorbs almost instantaneously
through the skin doing topically
and that's how it can be very beneficial
in decreasing inflammation and a joint
or like if you have a swollen knuckle
or if you have rheumatoid arthritis,
it can be beneficial.
The negative of it is kind of like any other product.
Like we've talked about methylene blue
or we could even use the same discussion
with bed med is all Ivermectin
is that there's people that go and write a little short,
little book about the benefits of DMSO
or Ivermectin or some people
who miss their practice on these things.
And they also have toxic side effects
because DMSO can be a methyl donor,
it can basically turn off your tumor suppressor system.
But because it's so anti-inflammatory,
it can help a cancer as well.
So there's a danger in doing a DMSO
topically over let's say a breast cancer
because in one sense the positive side
it could be anti-inflammatory
and it take down the inflammation
that's around a growing cancer
so that your immune system can get out and kill it.
That would be the positive side.
Then there isn't negative side to so many of these things.
So this isn't a natural supplement
that is not gonna have any negative things
or it's not gonna spare normal cells
and it's gonna change your physiology.
It's changing the what's going on
metabolic in your body.
So just like doing chemo,
chemo can kill cancer,
but chemo can also kill other cells.
Chemo's gonna kill your any rapidly growing cells
which are your immune system.
So then catch 22 with chemo
is that it can damage your body, it can kill you.
So you do chemo very carefully and sparingly
so that you don't kill the patient
before you kill the cancer and you're very careful with that.
Well, you have to be just as careful with fentanyzol
and I have hermectin and just as careful with something
even simple that you could buy on Amazon like DMSO
because it could have a negative effect
because the methyl groups could then be shutting off
the intrinsic apoptonic pathway
and could actually assist the growth of the cancer.
So the cancer isn't being killed from the inside out.
Does that mean I wouldn't use it?
No, it doesn't mean I wouldn't use it
but I'd be careful using it.
So if I was gonna put it on, first of all,
I probably would not use DMSO orally.
Now I know you could find some articles that DMSO
can help with decreased cancer.
They think it helps kill cancer.
I don't think so.
I think it decreases inflammation around the cancer.
So like I mentioned it can have a positive effect
but it can also have a negative effect.
It's the same thing with Ivermectin.
You hear all this stuff about Ivermectin,
Ivermectin, Ivermectin,
Ivermectin is all for me, it doesn't work on everybody.
And it can be cause ill effects on some people.
It's not this magic thing.
Matter of fact so much of Ivermectin
that you could purchase now is tainted
with all sorts of stuff that affects you negatively.
It's still a drug.
So if you're gonna use DMSO, use it sparingly,
start really small, just be very careful.
Just like anything else, be extremely careful.
Typically functional doctors over the years
have used DMSO as a driver.
So they're like put zinc in DMSO.
Like we have a zinc product with DMSO
that we only sell to patients
and it's only to patients that I'm allowing to use.
And that's driving zinc into the site
because DMSO is absorbed like instantaneously
through the skin.
It also drags with it anything that's around it.
That's why one of the cardinal rules
was using DMSO topically, which typically
they don't already ever tell you this
was you gotta make sure your skin is extremely clean,
especially women who use lotions and stuff
might have chemicals in it.
You put DMSO over the top of that.
You're basically driving those chemicals
right into your tissue and into your bloodstream.
So you either have a very clean surface
or if you're trying to drive something in there,
you then you maybe put down an essential oil
or you're using zinc in the DMSO
to drive a specific thing into the tissue.
So there's a purpose for all these things
and they can have wonderful benefits, right?
But they could also have side effects.
You know, that's why, okay,
if you're gonna use curcumin,
is that, are you gonna have side effects for that?
Well, only if you have anybody to that,
which is gonna be a very small percentage of people,
you have like an allergy sensitivity to curcumin.
What, you know, can have a sensitivity to anything, right?
But if you're using a high-dose curcumin
or high-dose burberry or, you know, things like that,
it's gonna spare healthy cells.
Even, I've, even, even something like, layatril.
Okay, layatril, is that a drug?
I don't think so, no, that's a nutrient
that's found in aproposites.
It's not a drug.
It doesn't kill healthy cells.
Yeah, if you take 10 of them,
could you have ill effects of them?
Yes, but, you know, take it in the right dose
and you're, it spares healthy cells.
They can selenium, but a higher dose.
Read my article in Harneseed Oxidative Stress to Kill Cancer.
You'll see a lot of higher dose supplements
act as oxidative agents to cancer cells,
but don't act as oxidative agents to healthy cells.
So they don't cause oxidative damage to healthy cells.
They spare healthy cells while helping kill cancer cells.
Do I know, dealt with this for the 25 years
that I've been dealing 28 years,
I've been dealing with cancer patients,
and it's, there's all sorts of fads
that come out on the market
that everybody needs to be on this.
Everybody needs to be on rick Simpson oil.
Everybody needs to be on venment as all.
Everybody needs to be on iron record.
I'm about to say there's, that you can't try things
and they can be miraculous to people.
But everybody doesn't need to be on anything.
You know, so it's just,
you've got to go slow with these things
to make sure you don't have side effects.
Next question.
My mom has been on the recommended supplement protocol
for about two weeks and is experiencing diarrhea.
It was recommended that we discontinue all supplements
and then slowly introduce them to determine the source.
What's the best way to do this?
She's also drinking lemon water regularly.
Could that be causing the diarrhea, not the supplements?
Well, the lemon water could be,
but if she was drinking lemon water before this,
then I would say probably not.
But if your answer to that question would be,
well, yeah, she actually just started
drinking lemon water at the same time.
Well, maybe, maybe.
So when you have an adverse reaction,
and I would say having diarrhea is an adverse reaction
to anything, you got to discontinue
what you changed when this new symptom started.
So you got to look back and tell you
if the best you could do and say,
well, yeah, it was right when we started all this.
Okay, then you're just going to take everything out
and go back on one of the time, give it three of,
take everything out and tell her diarrhea goes away
and then go back on one of the time that didn't cause it.
Let's go back on this one.
That didn't cause it.
If you need help on which is the most important
to go back on first, I will help you with that.
So just contact me.
But you just got to, it's a process of elimination.
This is an uncommon with people, especially if we're
a little bit older, that our system can just want to flush.
It's just irritating our system and we're just not
absorbing well.
And honestly, it might actually be the,
it might not be the nutrient in the pill.
It might be the capsule.
That could be an irritant.
I've had that happen where people would just open up
the capsule and put it there smoothie
and then they did everything problems.
So we just got to figure that out.
Next question, I purchased a rebuilder.
The rebuilder is that unit, that little electrical unit
that helps with neuropathy.
I purchased a rebuilder to address neuropathy from chemo.
On your website, you tell those who purchased this item
to buy a divided container to use with a rebuilder.
Yes, one of those little divided buckets
that you'd get at Walmart that you would carry
your cleaning supplies around with or your gardening supplies
around with.
It's like a bucket on each side in a handle in the middle.
So I did that.
I read the complete directions to the rebuilder that says nothing
about using a divided container.
So I'm confused what's the purpose of needing that.
So I don't know why the rebuilder doesn't have that data.
But you have to use a divided container,
fill both sides up with water, use the rubberized leads,
connect that to the lead itself, the little rubber pads.
You drop the rubber pads in each side of the water,
put your feet in there, then you turn the thing up
and tell your comfort level is comfortable.
And any 15 to 30 minutes is recommended.
Typically, they've done studies on it.
Even though I think they recommend 30 minutes per session,
90% of the treatment is done in the first 15 minutes.
So it depends on what your time frame is.
Next question.
I had to do a fleet saline animal for constipation issues.
The direction said to lie on my left side.
Your coffee animal directions say to lie down
on the right side.
What's the difference between left and right?
Well, the reason why they're having you
do, they're exhuming that you're buying the fleet animal
because your constipated line at your left side
is going to allow the fluid to go a little bit higher
into your rectal area, hopefully loosen up the mass
that you may have blockage in your colon.
Your right side, laying on your right side,
the fluid is more apt to get to the vagal nerve.
That's the stimulant that we want to do with coffee
animals.
So the general coffee animal direction
to stimulate your vagal nerve is your line
on your right side and then on your back and get it up.
Now, again, by easy, busy way of doing a coffee animal
is you're just standing up in the shower doing the coffee animal.
And I have said over and over again, that yeah,
well, it might be a little bit better lying down and lying
down on your back and then rolling to your right side.
So you're going to get baby a little more stimulation
of your vagal nerve.
It can be more difficult.
It can be messy.
It can be, it could make a person less apt to do a coffee
animal.
So I think it's best just to do the easy,
busy way stated up in the shower.
It's going to be easier.
You're going to be more apt to do it.
And that's going to be better.
So yeah, so whichever way you need to move around
to get your balls moving, the better off you could be.
And if you have constipation issues, there's nothing
wrong with doing a coffee animal for constipation.
You don't need to, if you already have an animal kit,
there's a reason you need to go by saline animal.
The saltwater isn't going to really produce
more of an anti constipation benefit
than just doing a coffee animal.
Just if you should, if you're regular constipation issues,
do more coffee animals per day.
You could do up to five a day.
And again, look at my constipation.
Know how, or I think it's something to start typing constipation
in the blog post, and I have a set of information
that you should go through if you have constipation.
Start off by taking some magnesium at night.
Then maybe some, if you still have issues,
and you still have issues with constipation
by doing coffee animals, coffee animals would
be the best thing for you, because they
have the other benefits of the coffee
animal by stimulating your immune system,
by stimulating your parasympathetic,
getting your vagal nerve going.
But then, you know, still having issues,
then look at using super allo, which is the Cape allo products.
So Cape allo will help is the best, I think,
help for constipation issues.
My eye doctor says it's that I have scleritis in my left eye
inflammation.
I've had this before.
But I just used apple cider vinegar, vitamin C powder,
and inner defense oil, and it goes away.
She wants me to take predisone.
What say you?
It's been way more painful and lasted longer this time.
That's why I went in.
OK, so predisone is going to be a very, very strong
anti-inflammatory drug, and it will probably
take care of the inflammation.
However, it is also something that will reduce your immune
response.
And short term predisone use, is that going to be bad?
Well, it depends.
If they're putting you on a predisone paper,
we're starting at 60 milligrams and 40 milligrams and 30
milligrams and 20 and 10 and such, something like that.
Is that a lot of predisone?
Yeah, well, yeah, it is.
We have brain cancer patients that are on predisone daily,
but they're on like 4 milligrams.
So if you could do it naturally, that's
going to be your best interest.
Do look out your right.
If there's any right programs for eye inflammation,
blood inflammation programs in your life,
anything you can try to do naturally,
you're going to be much better than taking a drug.
The negatives of taking the anti-inflammatory medications
are they have the side effects of reducing your immune system
function.
So if you could do it naturally, always try to do it naturally.
I'm still having a lot of issues with panic attacks.
They stop for a handful of days, but then they come back
with a vengeance.
I can't figure out why, as I am taking all the things you
recommended, wondering if doing a neurotransmitter
panel would help.
Yeah, we can do a neurotransmitter panel.
That's a possibility.
I do think doing a Cyrix 7x would be in order.
That's to see if you have antibodies to neural tissue.
I think that would be the most appropriate one.
If you do a neurotransmitter panel, they're
not super accurate tests because your neurotransmitters
are not just used in your brain.
So neurotransmitters are used at all your synapses of all your
neurons, which is all over your body.
So it's not just measuring brain neurotransmitter function.
So your brain are finding out why you have inflammation
in the brain and doing a Cyrix 7x.
So I'm not opposed if you're wanting
to do a neurotransmitter panel.
So contact me and we could get that ordered.
Does the Dutch test include that as well as adrenal hormones?
So the Dutch test only includes cortisol levels and DHA.
And it gives you a cortisol rhythm.
So your cortisol is released in a rhythm
as well as many of your hormones are.
And you have to make sure you do it on a day that is you're
not under a lot of stress or it kind of invalidates it.
But it's going to give you the cortisol rhythm
through the day.
You're taking a test through four different tests
through the day to get the cortisol rhythm.
That could be a beneficial test.
But that's really measuring just your needles.
So that's going to measure what that will tell you
is if your rhythm is still good, you still have a nice rhythm.
But everything is suppressed.
That means you have a adrenal fatigue.
If your rhythm, if everything is high,
then you have an excess cortisol output
and just excess product stress.
Or if it's just flatline, it means
you have complete adrenal, just complete adrenal fatigue
or what's it called, just complete adrenal waste
that we really need to get into support of your adrenal glands.
So there's benefit in doing cortisol rhythm tests.
I think there's benefits to that.
A CT scan on Monday showed that the cancer
has grown and spread.
Sometimes I am unable to keep my supplements down.
Are there any other alternative forms
or additional supplements that may be taken
to help slow the cancer growth?
So yeah, we should set up a time to talk
because it's this supplements.
I don't know how long you've been taking the supplements.
Definitely, if you have trouble keeping supplements down
in the form that you're taking,
and I think you're assuming that you're talking about
the pill form, maybe you're throwing them up
or it's hard to get them down,
to open them up and put them in a smoothie
maybe in order.
Sometimes again, like that other question,
you can just be irritated from the capsule itself.
So opening up the capsule, if it's...
You're safe to open up any capsule
unless it's a time-release supplement.
And it would say that on the bottle.
And there's not that many time-release supplements
that we are recommending to people.
But if it's not a time-release supplement,
you could open up the capsule
and put it in a smoothie or put it in a drink
and drink it down.
Typically, if you put it in a liquid
that isn't a smoothie or something like that,
it might stick to the sides
and you're really not getting much of it down.
But so putting it in a smoothie
and drinking the smoothie over the course of the day
is probably the best way to get that in.
Are there alternative forms?
We've had some people that were not eating anything,
maybe even had a feeding tube.
So we had to use an all-liquid supplement diet.
Lots of times the liquids will be in a tincture.
They're not extremely, you know, tasteful.
But if you have a feeding tube, you're not tasting them.
But if you're drinking them still by mouth,
you're tasting them and that can make you nauseous.
So that does become more difficult.
I would suggest, oh, try opening them up,
putting them in a smoothie and sipping the smoothie down
might be the best choice to begin with.
Okay, questions from the chat.
This question, can I travel with the right machine
and if so, is it okay to be in the same house
as a pregnant woman?
Yes, you can travel with the right machine.
Just be very careful and wrap it up.
Make sure you're very careful with the bulb.
We've had a number of people send a bulb back,
say their bulb's not working and it's broken
in the inside and the ends.
If you drop these bulbs and it falls on a bed
and it hits just wrong on its end,
it will break the glass in there
and it doesn't look like it's broken.
So you're looking at it, I don't see anything broken,
I don't see anything wrong with it, but it doesn't work.
And then you open it up on our side and it's broken.
All the gas is gone, it's not gonna work.
So you have to be really, really careful with the bulbs.
The machines are a little bit harder, but again,
if you're dropping the machine or it's bonking through,
you know, an airplane, you know, you could break it.
It's a very delicate instrumentation on the inside.
If you open up the machines, you could see how bonking
this thing around, these little tiny wires could break loose.
We had somebody ship a machine back to us
and there was multiple broken things now.
I don't put all the fault on the person who shipped it back to us
because it went back and forth with the post office
and the box was damaged.
So I don't know who stepped on it and who ran over
with their truck.
But when you open up the box, it was hardly wrapped.
So part of it, the fault had to fall
under that person who shipped it back to us.
You have to wrap these things up really good.
You have to be really careful with them.
So by all means, you can travel with your right machine.
I've always traveled with my right machine
and have had no problems, but I'm very careful
how you wrap it up.
Can you be in the house with the same house
as a pregnant woman?
Yes, you can.
Next question from the chat.
I'm wondering if you have thoughts on Moringa.
Benefits, concerns also regarding hormone-positive breast
cancer would it be OK to use Moringa?
Maybe.
So Moringa, I think, is a huge benefit.
So most, I don't think it raises your hormone levels.
I know it can be used to help balance hormones.
But I don't think it's elevating estrogen
or progesterone in itself.
So I'm a big fan of Moringa.
We have that in our, I think that's
in our medicinal mushroom mix that we have.
But it can be a great nutritional supplement.
Again, that's a natural thing.
Next question from the chat.
I've been on your metastatic prostate cancer diet
and supplement program as well as the right machine
for two years now.
I did receive three injections of antigen deprivation drug
and then stopped.
It's been a year and a half since I stopped them.
My monthly PSA results have been consistently less than 0.02.
Should I continue the same protocol or should I
get an updated plan for you?
Well, if you're getting these results,
if your last PSA was still in that range,
to be honest, I wouldn't change a thing.
So I wouldn't, I don't think there's a need.
So again, here's the real question.
When should I do a cheek swab test?
What should I do another cheek swab test?
Well, when you just start with me,
it can be good to do a cheek swab test within 60 days
just to make sure we tweak things and we get things going.
If you've been going with us for two years now
and you're having wonderful benefits,
it's like, would you run to the doctor
and make a change to your lifestyle?
You're doing well.
So why would you make giant lifestyle changes?
You don't necessarily want to make protocol changes
if you're doing really well.
So I'd say, stay the course.
Next question from the chat.
I'm hoping to understand the right machine even more.
Sometimes in the night when I wake up,
the light is very warm.
Should I be concerned?
No.
So at different frequencies,
the light is going to heat up more
than at other frequencies, number one.
And if you have less circulation,
meaning you happen to be laid on the bulb,
you happen to be holding a tight,
you happen to be under the covers,
the situation with where the bulb was placed
at that given time would also not allow air circulation
and could result in a hotter bulb.
There's no concern with that.
It itself is not going to burn out the bulb.
Also, I wonder if I should be repositioning
the light along my body throughout the week.
I've been keeping it near my chest every night
as I am treating breast cancer.
I would keep doing exactly what you're doing.
I always think that it's best,
even though you're going to get adequate treatment,
even if the bulb is a foot away from you
or even a couple feet away from you,
you're going to get better treatment closer it is to you.
And it makes sense to have it even closer
to the area in question.
So I would keep it right.
If you have breast cancer
and that's what you're treating,
I would be snuggling it the best you can
right over your breast.
Next question.
I recently had some conjunctival eye hemorrhage,
maybe due to supplements.
Should I run the Bursted Eye Vessel Rife program
and does it tend to strengthen the capillaries?
I also have Von Wilderberg blood clotting disorder.
I would say, yeah, you're not going to hurt yourself
writing any of the frequencies on the rife,
except the caveat that I've always said
is if you're running kill programs on, let's say,
live disease and you kill bacteria,
grab negative bacteria too quickly.
But no, the only caveat to this is,
I don't know how well it's going to work.
I mean, when I said, I don't know
that I don't remember anybody ever telling me
they had this condition and they ran the rife program
for it period.
So I have no data whether it's going to work or not.
So again, these are frequencies to help your body function better.
They're not, it's not going to miraculously cure anything,
but it certainly can help heal, help your body heal things.
So I would definitely give that a shot.
Next question about the rebuilder.
The rebuilder direction say to put the rubber leads directly
on your hands or feet.
Yes, you can do that.
In fact, you can't actually put sticky, sticky leads on them
like it tends you to put that directly on your hands
and feet.
The negative of doing that is that you're only
going to treat really that area.
By putting it in water, you're treating your whole foot
or your all your hands, you're hitting all those nerves
at the same time.
You're just making way better use of your time
than putting the lead on your head with a sticky pad
or the rubber pad and holding it down with a tape or something.
So it's just much better use of your time following
what I said by putting it in water.
I know it's a little bit of a hassle,
but you're going to get much better treatment by doing it in water.
Next question.
Pet scan is clear.
What does this physiological avidity throughout mean?
So I think you're asking a question
about when the radiologist says physiology,
physiologic avidity throughout.
Meaning that he, that just I believe means
that he's able to see what he was looking for.
So if everything is clear on your pet scan,
nothing is lighting up on the pet scan.
That's a good thing.
But just like we talked about, and I'm not
trying to burst a bubble, but I just want to say,
this is just one test.
So I think people have made the mistake of listening
to their oncologists and say, oh, great, your cancer free.
And then, they can let down their guard
and not treat themselves as if they have cancer.
And not that we want to ever act in fear or anything like that,
but we also want to act in wisdom.
So we don't let down our trust in our Heavenly Father
that he is the one healing us, the one who is sustaining us.
And I know you who are asking this question
who would never do this anyhow,
but you're keeping your faith in him
that he's going to continue to sustain every physiological process
every millisecond of the day.
So that's great news.
It's fantastic news, but we keep up the course.
Next question from the chat.
I'm going to the oncologist on Monday.
He's going to go over my guardian 360 test.
He ran it to see if I'm resistant to any drugs.
Is there any other info on there that would be useful to me?
I don't know how to read it
and what to look for.
I don't know.
I'd have to look at that.
I don't I'd have to look at your guardian 360 again
to be able to answer that question.
And make sure you read through all the other data in the test
to see if there's any information that would help you there.
Next question.
What are some other natural ways to reduce
eye inflammation besides the rife?
I've been doing the rife and it has helped.
And so one of the things that you want to look at,
whatever you have, OK, I have eye inflammation.
The first thing you want to ask your question,
ask yourself, and you probably already have, is why?
So why do I have eye inflammation?
Was there an irritant?
Did I, was I exposed to something?
Is it a histamine type reaction in my eye?
I mean, like an allergic reaction.
We're at that time of year where that's a possibility
where there's a lot of allergens in the air.
Is it something else that I have used a cream on my face
or something like that that could have been an irritant?
So do ask that question and kind of put your Sherlock Holmes
hat on and see if there was anything that caused that inflammation.
There are some nutrients for eye issues
that people have purchased on our store.
I don't know the validity of all of those things.
I know in the past that I remember, actually,
it was one of my first cancer patients ever way, way back
in the early, in the late 90s that her friend came in with her.
And she had a blocked eye duct.
And they were going to actually, she was scheduled for surgery.
And she had a bunch of swelling around her eye.
And they were going to go in there.
Actually, she was explaining to me the surgery
that they have to literally go in there with a drill bit
to drill that out.
And her, this is what we did right in the office.
And I actually said, well, let's do the right one.
And let's see if that helps.
And actually, we did the right one.
And she came back with her friend the next visit,
which I think was like two days later.
And she said, it's all gone.
She can't hold her surgery.
I mean, just one treatment with the right
made open up to that duct.
So if you have, there's other causes to it.
There's other issues that you can have with an eye
that could be in infection.
So if you have bacterial infection or viral infection,
you might want to address that and address that with the right.
So if you're running the right unjust inflammation,
that will help with inflammation,
but still not addressing the reason why,
because the reason why a person could have inflammation
is because of a virus or because of a bacteria.
So you'd have to do a little investigation.
I don't, I don't off the top of my head know
the most common eye bacterial infections.
And what bacteria it is, but if you did Google that,
just Google the most common bacterial eye infections
or viral eye infections.
And then whatever that comes up in that Google search,
you could just run that program on your right,
because most likely your right has that bacteria
in the list, in the alphabetical list.
It's thought that it's a virus
that you could run the viral program as well.
So there's this viral complex program
of the rife that may be extremely helpful.
Next question from the chat.
Generally speaking, how successful is rife for colon cancer?
It's very successful for colon cancer.
There's not very many cancers that we haven't seen
literally miracles with the rife machine.
But the truth is, is that you don't see miracles
with the rife machine with every person regardless
of what cancer it is.
So, but I can't think of one cancer
that I would say, oh, the rife just doesn't work for that
because we have had people, you know,
I've been doing this a long time.
And we've treated just about every cancer
you could think of, even rare ones.
And we've seen miracles with all of them.
So, but certainly, it certainly doesn't work for everybody.
It's not a magic weapon for cancer.
Though again, I've said over and over,
I wouldn't try to treat cancer without it.
But yeah, certainly if I had cancer,
if I had colon cancer, any cancer,
I'd be using the rife.
Okay, I think that will close off the day.
Thank you for all for being out here.
No, that will be praying for you
and a get a reminder to everybody to be prayed for each other.
It's always good to take our focus off ourselves
and see what our mission is that God has for us.
And that's what we should be asking on a daily basis.
Heavenly Father, what do you have for me to do today?
How can I exalt your name?
How can I bless you?
How can I just bring, bring blessing into your kingdom?
And you know, you think,
oh, well, I can't do this.
I'm sick or I'm not feeling well or how can I do this?
You can do it by being in deep prayer for other people.
So encourage you to see people on here.
You see, hear people's questions.
You might not know them personally,
but be praying for everybody.
Know that we're praying for you and God bless all of you
and we'll talk to you next week.
Bye-bye.